und wir zeigen Ihnen hier in dieser
Sendung ein Bild des Todes an einem
Traumstrand ein massenhaftes wahlsterben
vor der australischen Küste
230 Wale warum sind sie alle hier
gestrandet alle gemeinsam das ist das
todesrätsel um 230 Wale
es ist ein wahrer Albtraum der sich vor
einer Traumkulisse abspielt ein
wahldrama 230 Grindwale haben sich aus
bislang ungeklärten Gründen in einer
abgelegene Bucht verirrt tragisch die
Hälfte der Tiere ist bereits tot die
Massenstrandung gibt den Forschern
Rätsel auf seltsam fast auf den Tag
genau vor zwei Jahren waren schon einmal
hunderte Wale in derselben Gegend
gestrandet
Meeresbiologen versuchen nun fieberhaft
eine Erklärung zu finden eine mögliche
Ursache die höheren Wassertemperaturen
wegen des Klimawandels eine andere
Erklärung ist die enge Bindung die die
Wale untereinander haben das heißt sie
lassen Kranke Artgenossen nicht im Stich
ein angeschlagenes Tier könnte sich also
in die Bucht verirrt haben und die
anderen folgten den Rettern in
Australien bleibt momentan nur eins
versuchen so viele Tiere wie möglich zu
retten
[Musik]
sprechen wir darüber mit Meeresbiologin
Tamara naganes homefeld vom whale and
Dolphin conversation schön dass ihr hier
bei uns sind haben sie irgendeine
Erklärung dafür wie es dazu kommen
konnte dass so viele Wale dort stranden
und weil es sind leider die häufigsten
an Massenstrandung beteiligt Spezies und
es liegt eigentlich eben wie auch in
ihrem Beitrag bereits genannt an der
sehr engen und stabilen sozialen
Gruppenstruktur die sie haben sie haben
nämlich immer ein Leittier das sozusagen
die Richtung angibt und alle
Gruppenmitglieder folgen dem Tier aber
eben wenn es eine Krankheit innerhalb
der Gruppe ist oder auch ein
Navigationsfehler der leider öfter in
Tasmanien vorkommt vorkommt dass dann
eben zu massenstrahlungen kommt weil sie
dann in flachen Gewässern sind und nicht
mehr rauskommen und dann stranden
jetzt frage ich mal ganz
unwissenschaftlich nach das sind doch
eigentlich ganz schlaue Tiere und die
schwimmen dann alle im Grunde dumm dem
Leid hier hinterher ins Verderben
also ich würde nicht von Dummheit
sprechen aber eben eine sehr starke
emotionale Bindung und wenn sich auch
also in Sachen Gewässern kommt manchmal
die ökolokation vor allem von zum
Beispiel grindwein die normalerweise in
sehr tiefen Gewässern eben auch jagen
manchmal etwas durcheinander weil
natürlich im flachen Gewässern die
kolokation viel früher zurückkommt und
dass sie dann einfach total das
orientiert sind die Eco Location müssen
uns immer noch kurz erklären was ist das
ist eigentlich auch viel Fledermäuse
also sie geben einen Schall aus und
sobald der reflektiert reflektiert wird
also zum Beispiel vom Boden von Fischen
wenn sie sie jagen dann wissen sie kann
sie ungefähr Orten wo die sind also es
ist eigentlich wie wir Menschen sehen
nur benutzen Sie das so nah dafür also
quasi das hauseigene Wahl eigene Navi so
eine bisschen ist es ein Zufall dass das
jetzt genau ein Jahr später fast auf den
Tag genau dieses Phänomen dort an diesem
Strand wieder auftritt hat es irgendwas
auch mit den Jahreszeiten zu tun
also es ist schon sehr seltsam dass es
eigentlich sich zur selben Zeit am
selben Ort ereignet
eine Erklärung wäre eventuell dass es
sich halt um eine um dieselbe Population
handelt die halt eben zu der Jahreszeit
genau in dieser Gegenteil durchschwimmt
und das ist dann eben wieder
aus welchem Grund auch immer
navigationsstörungen oder sogar und das
ist deswegen zu einer sehr ähnlichen
Zeit zum selben Vorfall kam also sie
sind dort das haben sie gerade gesagt
nicht aus Dummheit alle miteinander
gestrandet sondern quasi aus Liebe wegen
ihres sozialen großen sozialen
Kompetenzen jetzt sind so viele Wale
dort gestorben an der Küste ich habe
über die Fotos gestaunt weil ich gar
nicht wusste dass die in so großen
Populationen gemeinsam schwimmen fehlen
da jetzt nicht ganz viele oder gibt es
tausende andere in der Ecke
also generell im ganzen antarktischen
Gebiet sozusagen gibt es über 200.000
und es gibt eben verschiedene
Subpopulationen also solche
Massenstrandungen vor allem in sehr
großer Zahl weil eigentlich spricht man
von massenstrahlungen sobald es mehr als
zwei Tiere sind aber in so großer Zahl
macht auf jeden Fall was mit der
Population also es wird auf jeden Fall
einen Effekt haben aber
es geht ihnen noch gut aber natürlich
macht es einen Unterschied wenn so viele
Individuen verloren gehen
vielen herzlichen dank ihnen für ihre
Einschätzungen zu diesem Thema 230 Wale
die dort gestrandet sind in Tasmanien
dort in einem Traumstrand und jetzt ums
Überleben kämpfen viele sind schon
gestorben danke
[Musik]